no
ciao bello testualità storia sono elite
io vitale e oggi andremo a vedere le
reazioni dei bambini alcuni sono bambini
viziati a regali molto fondate oppure le
reazioni di bambini a regali brutti
io sono troppo quello mi dispiace per
quelli che riceveranno i regali brutti
perché prima tristezza vedere nell'area
essere perso con questo per curiosa di
vederle oggi siamo infatti in tema
natalizio in testa e vitale a mezzo
babbo natale di 3 euro
quindi tu sei il camino se l'entrata del
cammino però non è tenero e poi volevo
ricordare che il miglior regalo di
natale e il libro di vita stories
ovviamente ho dormito per ed i commenti
se l'avete già ordinato se ce l'avete
già o se lo avete chiesto babbo natale o
se lo avete chiesto qualcun altro
sarebbe i commenti è il regalo perfetto
che ne dici nei commenti qual è il
regalo più brutto che abbiate mai
ricevuto da chi perché se fosse spiegati
si e raccontarli sì anche come è
successo di tutto siamo super curiosi
potessero sapere nei commenti diamo due
bambini e un albero di natale questo non
so se sia quello che il regalo il brutto
o che sono quelli viziati perché sono un
po un mix vi diamo dicendo questo è
quello che volevi che cos'è questa
sembra una cosa giusta per bambine
ma per noi il titolo principe e poi non
c'è niente di male comunque lo può
mettere anche un regalo il bambino un
maschietto il vestito da principale
volevo qualcosa prelevati paul unicorno
rosa è visto non lo voglio fratello
stato la principessa no oggi come trama
utilizzare tuo figlio ce la siamo a
questa cosa prossimo questo non è un
bambino però
a dei quaderni primo quaderno grande
produca del rovigo me stesso penso che
sia grande abbastanza queste rosso oddio
santo allora traduciamo un momento è
arrabbiatissimo perché così facendo ogni
anno chiaro un calendario grafico grande
per sti per le cose e ogni anno mi dai
parola ci metto questo qua è un avevano
taccuino è che noi magari indebolita
quindi ci sono le date comunque ma
perché mi arrabbiai per me fai mi diceva
io non riesco a scriverci in questi
troppo piccoli ma anche grandi premesse
per avviare così tanto poveretto la
mamma o chi è
ha detto che ogni volta che vengo qua
succede questo ogni volta succede e ha
buttato taccuino mi dispiace ma vediamo
questi bambini che tutto era cambiato
non sei riconoscente no
no dai così proprio ma il bacio fare
altre cose visto che di sotto per punire
il gabinetto non lo vuole no
[Musica]
vediamo domani
il sacchetto di arance o cipollari si
può il rispetto in colpa che sorridendo
perché vede i tuoi lascerà mamma che
giungano i cattivissimi obiettivo
offrire non un cane per altri
chi ha paura ma questa roba è qualcosa
di blu che come ha già capito cos'era e
nero della sorella dilaniamo il
cagnolino cagnolino quel loro
elettronico
quindi questo paese stia dalla parte dei
bambini viziati forse forse con la
mancia al the royal è però carino
vediamo siete stati davvero bravi che
stanno quindi potete aprire un regalo in
anticipo fi
chi era questo quello che volevo andare
in maniera sarcastica che cosa sembra un
giocattolo caino provocano ma mai
cambiato qualche tema sembrava un
giocato ha detto odio
ok forse è un po di ormai nel borsino la
forza perché li hanno investiti lui un
regalo da femminuccia lei da maschietto
non so cosa cambia lei sembra un pacco
di gomme da masticare catenella sono
forte buttata ma come sono tutti i
bambini che l'avrebbero apprezzato quel
gioco
mi sta dicendo tu non devi toccare i
regali scegliendo qua a paperino vediamo
in che cosa mai fatto se glielo altro mi
sa che quello che ho sempre voluto ha
detto un vuoto dice grazie non è un ipad
[Applauso]
un ipad per scrivere ai tag per scrivere
non piace un sacco sinceramente prima
quando sei piccolo non si ci rimani male
poi che ridono che prendono in giro con
rimane antin presto per quanto tempo non
è molto bello infatti se n'è andato a
tutela aperta non hai mattone è la
scatola di una nymex a ok è un euro è
vero è un thunderbolt display in pratica
prima ad apple faceva dei degli schermi
ora mi sa che non li vendono più lungo e
uno schermo aggiuntivo erano molto belli
grandi accontentare allegri mi piace o
forse voleva lei mail che gli hanno
fatto il grande schermo
vabbè ma va benissimo così tempistica
queste mutando tagliato in anticipo
ridere piangere e con la barba e meno
tua zia i giochi penso che siano dei
giochi comunque per bambini possono
avere una fidanzata è vero che da
piccola volevo che il maschio uno
[Applauso]
scatenato aiuto che vota no se qualcosa
deve di chips patatina ma tutti no è
incredibile la realizzazione ambito con
il mio organizzano e come me mi piace
mangiare
[Risate]
finalmente un regalo che si può mangiare
troppo bravo mi è piaciuto il regalo che
carino e poi apriremo un regalo sei
contento e molto sorriso aderiscono 1
poi più tardi ne puoi aprire altri pochi
che non si sa ma non posso mangiare bene
volevo questo natale ha detto che era la
mangio proprio paniere è una banana pc è
troppo grande da bambina di pazienza
diamo quando troveranno che il critico
organizzano bugiardo che ai file
tuttavia non gli piace la costanza di
peso e che stia qui al dj vaio è
contento comunque
ok abbiamo preso qualcosa per voi
sicuramente speciale e lo possono aprire
a tutti stai insieme
secondo me reagiscono bene perché sono
tutti e streghe quindi non è il regalo
di uno di loro magari personale non
sentono la pressione addosso da bambino
per la ma perché si è vestito in ipo da
laterale magari e da soldato è beccato
lega robe lì
tre sono felici tranne il piccolo che
ieri però tutti quanti vogliono pagare
la dati che consenta poi con il tuo
preferito
non posso si stanno mangiando le carote
ma non sono tanto gli utenti e non va
bene sta cominciando a fare rumore
che carini avete così bravi e un regalo
di natale in anticipo per ex
[Applauso]
mi dispiace perché ne rimarrà presto per
tutta la vita cav è bello quindi
espresso ieri all'educazione ragazzi
belli che avranno così fase attenzione
troppa paura che i migliori legale che
avrete mai tutta la vita la vita senza
casa si affaccia su piazza pace è stato
quant
[Applauso]
quello avevo in sé grazie mamma dicono
ma prima printer poi altri ingredienti
[Applauso]
puoi mettere una sana li puoi mettere
una tassa all'interno riscaldare al
microonde e può ottenere il suo latte
caldo durante tutto il giorno sparo e
divise ma l'altro gli skipass
un'occhiata e marco e vanessa de minico
cioè il cuore vuoi chiede c'è anche come
detto quando vai a cercare un tesoro con
il balcone di tesori puoi metterlo
acquatico inverno
[Applauso]
così nel mondo
no io è che quello fu il cane per
abbiamo piccola questo erano tutti dai
ragazzi romeni per oggi lascia team like
se volete vederne altre andremo a
vederne altre assieme io mi sento un po
tristi nello stesso tempo mi facevano un
po ma anche divertenti voi invece che
effetto vi facevano la sua sicurezza in
stampa della reazione che mi è piaciuta
di più che vi ha scioccato di più e noi
siamo un po 4 castellini e su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao